foreign
[Music]
welcome to the inauguration ceremony for
Spaceport S range it's a beautiful
winter day here in Northern Sweden and
we're so excited to have you with us
today we'll be celebrating a major space
milestone
Spaceport S range is the first space
station in Europe to offer satellite
launch services for the European
mainland
what's so special about that well it's
Swedish space Corporation we're on a
mission to help Earth benefit from space
by adding the capability of launching
satellites from European soil or
realizing one of our goals and helping
ensure peace prosperity and freedom for
the European Union and all of humanity
and this range is specially suited to
the task with the cooperation of the
Sami people and the reindeer herds SSC
maintains more than 500 square
kilometers of isolated Wilderness
perfect for launching satellites
our guest speakers today will include
the chair of Swedish space Corporation
Anakin Barbara the president of the
European commission Ursula vandelion the
prime minister of Sweden of christerson
and helping cut the ribbon none other
than his majesty the king of Sweden
other special guests will include the
director general of the European Space
Agency Executives from Marianas base
group isar Aerospace and OHP Sweden as
well as many other prominent industry
Representatives distinguished
Commissioners and ministers
while we're waiting for the ceremony to
begin let me tell you a little bit more
about S range and SSC
S range is one of the most versatile and
sustainable space stations in the world
and the main Hub of the SSC connect
Network
for over 50 years we've helped
scientists institutions and Commercial
companies access the wonders of space
SEC has launched over 700 sounding
Rockets from S range and over a thousand
stratospheric balloons
not only that SSC has ground stations
all over the world where we support
satellite Communications lunar missions
and launcher tracking we also provide
Engineering Services for manned missions
and data analytics for Global awareness
how do satellites help Earth benefit
from space the list of applications is
practically endless monitoring climate
change pollution deforestation
agriculture conservation and crisis
management these things go hand in hand
with the themes our attendees
we'll be discussing today including
Democratic Values a green transition
European competitiveness and security
Spaceport S range will help enable all
of this and much more by providing
access to space with a focus on security
and sustainability
thank you for your patience our guests
are touring the facility the ceremony
will begin shortly
foreign
the inauguration is about to start so
please can you join us by the main stage
the inauguration ceremony is about to
start so can you please join us by the
main stage thank you
once again welcome everyone
welcome to the inauguration for
Spaceport S range
the beautiful winter day here in
Northern Sweden and we're so excited to
have you with us today we're celebrating
a major space milestone
Spaceport S range is the first space
station in Europe to offer satellite
launch services from the European
mainland
what's so special about that well an SSC
space corporation that Swedish space
Corporation we're on a mission to help
Earth benefit from space
by adding the capability of launching
satellites from European soil we're
realizing one of our goals and helping
ensure peace prosperity and freedom from
the European Union and all of humanity
and S range is especially suited to the
task with the cooperation of the Sami
people and the reindeer herds SSE
maintains more than 500 square
kilometers of isolated wilderness
perfect for launching satellites
again speakers today will include the
chair of Swedish space corporation on
the kimberbatra the president of the
European commission Ursula vandalion the
prime minister of Sweden of christerson
and helping cut the ribbon none other
than his majesty the king of Sweden
on the special guests include the
director general of European Space
Agency Executives from Ariana space isar
space and OHP Sweden as well as many
other prominent industry Representatives
distinguished Commissioners and
ministers
while we're waiting for the ceremony to
begin
let me tell you a little bit more about
S range and SSC
Esser
your majesty
Madam president prime minister
commissioner ministers distinguished
guests ladies and gentlemen dear friends
and now also all of you watching us on
live stream
welcome welcome again to Sweden's
Spaceport since 1966 but from today the
Europe the EU mainland's first Spaceport
s-range in the North of Sweden as chair
of the Swedish space Corporation it's my
honor and pleasure to welcome you all
here and to today's
inauguration today it may feel like a
small step for us but this could be a
very important giant leap actually for
Europe
this third Swedish EU presidency must
prioritize security and space enables us
to be stronger on security it's space
enables us to be competitive since
everything digital and almost everything
in our everyday lives is reliant on
satellite networks which can be powered
here from and add this Spaceport
and space is important for
sustainability and the green transition
when we can watch the Earth and
understand what happens on it and even
under it we can be wiser on what to do
with the climate and how to help our
only planet
space enabled access to data information
and communication are strategic for any
leaders in the world which is why
European leaders need to invest in it
and I'm very happy to see all of you go
around looking at these areas of space
here today
these are key to a better Europe and the
world again let me thank you so much for
coming here it's a great honor and
pleasure for me to be part of this and I
will thank everyone who made this
today's inauguration possible
this inauguration of the EU mainland's
first Spaceport may feel like a small
step for us today but it enables giant
leaps for Europe ahead and now it's my
honor and pleasure to welcome you to the
inauguration itself
where we will have our most
distinguished guests we will see both
the prime minister of Christian Madam
president of the commissioner Ursula Van
Der Lyon and His Majesty the king of
Sweden starting with the Prime Minister
and my dear friend Earl klisterton
welcome
foreign
[Applause]
thank you so much Anna it's true
pleasure to be here your majesty ladies
and gentlemen
it's wonderful to be in this very
distinguished crowd here today for this
very special occasion
it's really been inspiring to listen to
previous speakers who really know what
they are talking about and it's clear
that exploring space helps us to
understand our place in universe
but space technology and data can also
be used to improve the conditions of
humankind on Earth climate change
mitigation is a priority and space data
is key to analyzing changing and
identifying effective countermeasures
space is a global common and we need to
have responsibility to Future
generations to secure that its use is
fair and sustainable
we should all be able to share the
benefits of space-based infrastructure
and services
this approach
also reflects the focus in the space
policy area of the Swedish presidency as
we strive for a Greener safer and Freer
Europe
therefore I am so pleased to be here at
S range today together with all of you
with a half a century of successful
space activities and some 600 launches
of sounding Rockets
the current geopolitical situation not
least of course the Russian invasion of
Ukraine has demonstrated how important
it is that the European Union has access
to space
S range unique geographical position and
long service makes it ideal for launches
of satellites in polar orbits and other
space activities
for this reason Sweden has invested in
the s-range lodge pad which will
strongly contribute to resilience and
access to space this is actually unique
it is the first facility of its kind of
Mainland Europe and I know that it is
made possible by teamwork with trusted
International partners
this range is also an excellent example
of how high quality Education and
Research are essential to our prosperity
and contribute to European long-term
competitiveness with these words I would
like to pass the floor to the president
of the European commission Ursula
fornalaya via Jerusalem please thank you
[Applause]
foreign
thank you very much prime minister
your majesty
colleagues from the college their
ministers distinguished guests president
of the Swedish space Corporation
director general of the European Space
Agency I am delighted to be here with
you today
to join this inauguration here
it's a big moment it's a big moment for
Europe
it's a big moment for Europe's space
industry
the first orbital launch site on
European mainland
this Spaceport offers an independent
European gateway to space
it is exactly the infrastructure we need
not only to continue to innovate
but also to further explore
the final frontier I was fascinating to
listen to the scientists that introduced
us to the different topics and
possibilities that are here
the important work you have been doing
here for many many years
is a shining example
of the enormous potential of space-based
research indeed to improve our daily
life
Galileo Copernicus the new Iris system
have been cited a lot today
and if you look at for example the green
transition one of the topics we've been
discussing here
climate change
well if we want to efficiently track
the effects of climate change
space provides 60 of the measurements we
need just look from space and you have
the majority of data that you need to
understand what's going on
or take civil protection
or traffic management
I will never forget the help of
Copernicus we got
amidst the pandemic when we had to
establish our green Lanes
to manage as best in a very critical
situation it was Copernicus who helped
us and gave us the data that were
necessary on a daily basis really to
make decisions that are crucial
this Leading Edge space port gives
Europe the capabilities to address this
growing demand
the benefits of small satellites that
can be launched from here are immense
we've just heard that it is important to
launch over and over these satellites to
have the reusability to test it
and I was thrilled to hear what is
necessary is not so much the investment
yes this is also necessary but it's the
political will so I say it to my
audience let's take this as a strong
message to show the political will
I've spoken about climate mitigation
but adaptation is equally important for
example we can track natural disasters
in real time
we will never forget and we've all seen
the terrible droughts and floods
and forest fires
and yes they are horrible but you have
to act instantly
and more eyes in the sky then are
crucial to help save lives in Europe and
around the world
small satellites we've heard that are
also important of importance for our
security
today we know that the brave Ukrainian
forces effectively uses small satellites
to track the movements of Russian troops
and because of this growing importance
overall many many topics that I couldn't
touch upon today the commission will
make a proposal for an EU Space strategy
for security and defense
the aim is
to improve the resilience of the
European space infrastructure
and strengthen our shared European
capabilities
finally
we are working tirelessly to change the
way we do space
this means encouraging the involvement
of smes and startups in EU Flagship
initiatives there's a lot to do we need
you
for example the Copernicus Dynamic
purchasing system
it also means promoting access to
finance for space entrepreneurs in
Europe
so there are so many good reasons why we
need to accelerate the European Space
Program
you show us the shining example for it
today
I would like to thank everyone involved
in this project
Europe has its foothold in space and we
will keep it thank you very much
[Applause]
and finally to conduct the inauguration
well please welcome his majesty the king
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
and last but not least I now give the
floor to conclude this to the first
Swedish astronaut Mr Christopher Dr
Christopher
now the countdown
10.
10 9
8.
7 6 5
4
3
2 1.
[Music]
for the benefit of humanity and in
European Union
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
space is the future and now from
Spaceport S range we're ready to take
you there if you have questions about
any of the advanced space services
offered by Swedish space Corporation
please send an email to info
sscspace.com thank you for watching